this panel is called capitalism and
poverty and our distinguished panelists
are going to pose and answer a number of
questions such as is capitalism moral is
capitalism fair is capitalism the right
approach for the developing world how do
the poor fair under capitalism indeed
how do alternative economic systems
treat the poor for the morally minded
amongst us how a system treats the least
among us is not an idle question and nor
should it be for any of us who are
interested in promoting freedom as
charles murray so nicely served up to us
last night we've kind of hit the end of
diminishing returns on what policy can
achieve for us what empirical data even
and the proofs of economics can do for
us we're at the point where we need to
have a cultural innovation and we need
to win the cultural war in favor of the
fairness of capitalism and this panel
will help us address that fundamental
question now this being the Hillsdale
College free-market forum there won't be
any doubt about the effect Ecosse of
markets about its utility but with their
help I hope we will begin to adjust the
question of how do we promote and sell
capitalism as a fair and just system to
help lead us off in this line of inquiry
this morning his professor Rose David C
Rose is a professor of economics at the
University of Missouri st. Louis his
latest book is entitled the moral
foundation of economic behavior and his
forthcoming book why culture matters
most will be from Oxford University
Press early next year 2015 he also
contributes actively to policy debates
through radio interviews and op-eds on
topics ranging from Social Security
monetary policy fiscal policy judicial
philosophy and healthcare reform his
Bachelor of degree in economics is from
Missouri State University and his PhD in
economics from the University of
Virginia
please join me in welcoming professor
Rose thank you for them
you've probably heard the old quip that
says it unless everyone's identical
equal treatment inevitably produces
unequal outcomes and forcing ago
outcomes inevitably requires unequal
treatment this quip highlights a
well-known distinction between two
different ways of thinking about
fairness and equality you know we can we
can think of fairness is receiving equal
treatment what we might call fairness
this process and we can think of
fairness as receiving equal payoffs what
one might call fairness is outcome today
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
talk about why capitalism is not in any
way unfair it's not unfair by a fairness
as process standard and it's not unfair
by a outcome standard the arguments I'm
gonna make are very very simple the
issues involved are very very simple but
as I'm sure you all know often the most
important things are so simple we skate
right over the top but that doesn't make
them any less important finally I hope
I'll close strong with an argument for
why capitalism if anything is more than
fair okay a capitalist and people who
are advocates of capitalism tend to
interpret unequal outcomes in a
free-market society as something that's
not terribly alarming something that's
kind of a natural byproduct of the fact
that people have different talents and
have different tastes some people have
very different tastes regarding effort
willing
to invest and you know taste for risk if
you have people in a system where the
rules of the game are consistently and
fairly applied these differences in
talents and tastes will inevitably
produce different outcomes and that's
pretty much the beginning an end of it
for them
so capitalism quite naturally does quite
well on a fairness as process kind of
standard and indeed if anything
capitalism is extremely dependent on
fairness as process when the rules of
the game are not fairly and
even-handedly applied it dramatically
increases the risk of doing anything of
any great merit and as a result
discourages people from doing the very
sorts of things that make capitalism an
engine for prosperity why well if the
rules of the game can be changed
willy-nilly from above and certainly
we've had a lot of experience with that
over last year's people who people who
might consider doing something
extraordinary have to worry about de
facto shakedowns from from the
government they also have to worry about
their competitors being favoured by the
government if their competitors happen
to be like with the government so this
is one reason why people who are either
capitalists or advocates of capitalism
or big fans at a rule of law in the rule
of law is nothing if not a plea for
fairness as a matter of process and rule
of law is not consistent with fairness
as a matter of outcomes although we have
a few Supreme Court justices that don't
seem to understand that okay so why is
capitalism not unfair even by a process
standard well I'm sorry
next slide as an outcome standard on my
capital with social justice there's view
fairness as something that is pretty
much for the most part only a matter of
outcomes when they see when they look at
the free market society and they see
that some people have far more than
others they immediately suspect that
something is awry now
what's what's really particularly
interesting about their position now is
even if they can't point to some aspect
of the processes unfair this in other
words they can't see how there's
anything unfair about the process itself
if they see an unequal outcome they view
it as if so facto evidence of unfairness
for them unequal outcomes equals unfair
what I'm gonna argue now though is that
even by the implicit moral standards
employed by people who favor social
justice Theory capitalism is
indisputably fair now how could it
possibly be how could how could social
justice service be so wrong well I'm
going to explain why social justice here
is simply don't think carefully enough
about the nature of cooperation
cooperation is a hugely important thing
to get right because if you think about
it capitalism is so spectacularly
successful at fostering human
flourishing and advancement because it
does the best job of any known system
for supporting cooperation so if you
don't get the basics of cooperation
right you're gonna miss the whole point
about capitalism and that's what I think
that they do ok let's talk about
cooperation there's me on the left and
there's you I hope you don't mind being
treated as a randomly drawn young woman
and what this signifies is it alone I
make 10 units of something alone you
make 10 units of something but when we
work together and you see the two
pictures stuck together this means we're
not like a team a cooperative node we
work together we make 26 not not 20 but
26 and the point of this is to capture
the idea that the whole is greater than
to some other parts and that is the
essence of cooperation when we work
together we do better than when we work
alone added up that difference is known
as the co-operative surplus and it's a
measure of how important cooperation is
and it's a measure of how strongly two
people might be attracted to each other
to cooperate so in this example the
co-operative surplus is clearly six now
one thing that's cool about the
co-operative surplus is that the
co-operative surplus is what explains
why people are willing to voluntarily
cooperate for people to voluntarily
enter into transactions with each other
in order to cooperate
has to be in both of their best
interests so the transaction has to be
mutually beneficial well the only way it
can be mutually beneficial is if there
something being produced beyond the sum
of the parts that can be divided between
them
cooperative surpluses all are important
in an even deeper way general prosperity
is basically the amount of goods and
services we have per person that's what
it is you cannot increase the amount of
goods and services per person by just
moving goods and services around you
still end up with the same amount of
goods and services per person what
capital societies do though is they
create incentives that induce people to
cooperate and as they cooperate each one
of those nodes of cooperation is
producing that little surplus so there's
an extra six floating around or an extra
ten or next 420 that indeed increases
the amount of goods and services per
person so cooperative surpluses are the
key
they are the cynical known of general
prosperity so if they're so important
where do they come from
well cooperative surpluses come from
cooperative synergies and there's all
kinds of them I can't cover any more
than a couple but I'm showing two guys
here carrying a couch because anyone
who's ever carried a couch knows that
two guys are way more productive than
twice one it's not even close but by far
and away the most important source of
cooperative synergy is the one that we
all know from Adam Smith's famous pin
Factory example when people get together
work together and divide up tasks to
effectuate gains from specialization
through the division of labor their
productivity goes up dramatically we're
talking about tens of thousands of
percent I've actually worked us out and
I require my students to do that it's
really astounding the increase in output
the results from cooperation okay so
we're cooperating and cooperating is
good and a natural question is how
should we divide the output from
cooperation well first let's zero in on
the surplus that ten that I produce an
attendant you produce that's mine that's
yours that's what you gave up but the
six of the surplus that really isn't
mine and that's not yours in no way
shape or form it truly is
I couldn't have made it without you you
couldn't made it without me so as a
result neither one of us has a stronger
claim on that six as a result the
simplest thing to do is just split it
down the middle now there are very good
economic reasons political reasons
sociological reasons anthropological
reasons for why we do this and even
social justice theorists would readily
agree that evenly splitting cooperative
surpluses is the way to go and I believe
it's the way to go and I'm gonna argue
later that that's what the way it
normally works out so how should the
other 20 units be allocated we've got
twenty six six normal surplus the other
twenty what are we do those well those
other twenty units are properly thought
of as our respective opportunity costs
paying everyone their opportunity costs
as part of the payoff of the of the
endeavor is only fair because it
compensates people for what could be
unequal contributions it would be rather
like if anita paid everyone reimbursed
everyone the average amount for airfares
when some people traveled from much
greater distance it had to pay more that
would be nonsense that would be patently
unfair even under a fairness as outcome
standard so you gotta pay people their
opportunity cost and there's no way you
can pay anybody more than your
opportunity cost without paying somebody
less than their opportunity cost by
construction of the example okay so what
does that mean well that means my payoff
is the 10 that I would have made that I
sacrificed by cooperating with you
because I can't make it now to the
unincorporated with you plus my share to
surplus purchase tree your payoff is the
10 you could have made the 10 you
sacrifice by cooperating with me plus
your half at a surplus which is an
another 3 and therefore 13 so we both
get paid 13 in this case very simple now
in this particular example equally
splitting the surplus results in an
equal split of the final output so you
might be saying well what's what's the
point of this example this sure sounds
like what the social justice here is for
advocating well the problem is in the
real world things are almost never this
simple in the real world were confronted
with examples like this in the real
world we have a situation where somebody
like me makes to working by myself
somebody like you you guys
are obviously more productive than I am
makes 10 and together we make 16 so this
is a different payoff structure
different different game now
should we cooperate while cooperation is
still very much in both our interest the
whole of 16 is greater than the
summative parts of 12 there's a
cooperative surplus of 4 so it makes
sense for us to work together for us to
cooperate but the payoffs now are gonna
be a little different you see my payoff
is the two that I get to cover my
opportunity cost for having sacrificed
my time
plus my share of surplus which is also
two two plus two is four your payoff is
the ten that you had to sacrifice you
had to sacrifice far more in order for
us to cooperate and your half at a
surplus which is ten so your payoff is
twelve so by my reckoning
you should get three times more than me
which is probably the best thing you've
heard since this conference started
right and as some third party who's not
looking carefully at the inputs this
looks like a gross inequity this
couldn't possibly be fair but I'm gonna
argue that it's indisputably fair by the
fairness is out from standard look
everyone's getting an equal share of the
surplus there's no question that that is
fair by the fairness is out from
standard but at the same time everyone
is get is bearing an equal part of the
burden of making the output possible
because they're all being fully restored
and no more for their personal
opportunity cost
so both elements of this payoff are fair
as a matter of outcome now to see why
this is an important thing to for people
to understand let's suppose that there's
a rule that says we have to split output
evenly we need to quote spread it around
a little more close quote
well in that case the payoff would be 16
divided by 2 which is 8 for each of us
right now what would you do you can make
10 by yourself or you can cooperate with
me put up with me and get 8 what you
gonna do
my guess is you're not going to
cooperate with me
well in that case everybody loses I fall
from getting for only getting to because
I don't have you to work with you fall
from getting 12 to getting 10 so if we
force equal sharing of output in the
name of social justice we should be
clear that the result is either that
will have less prosperity because
someone like you will choose not to
cooperate with someone like me or less
freedom because you were forced to
cooperate with me against your will it's
got to be one or the other
think of it this way if fairness is all
about equality so inequality is bad then
inequality shall also be bad with
respect to bearing an unequal burden of
the input contribution so my first big
claim is that paying people their
opportunity costs plus an equal share of
the surplus satisfies the fairness
outcome standard my second big claim is
that capitalism is therefore fair by the
fairness as outcome standard because it
drives us to these very kinds of
solutions now why would that be true
well capitalism endorses honest
competition and voluntary transacting so
everyone has to be paid their
opportunity costs are they won't enter
into these transactions to begin with so
there's not going to be any unequal
burdens imposed by input contribution at
the same time competition in a
capitalist system drives equal splitting
of surpluses just think about it
you can transact with somebody but two
people they're identical one person
wants three-fourths of the surplus the
other will go for half who do you think
always gets left on the sidelines the
dominant strategy is for everyone to
propose and everyone to accept an equal
split of genuine surpluses so capitalism
is inherently fair by the fairness as
outcome standard now I'm going to make
what I hope you view is an incredible
claim that capitalism isn't just fair
it's more than fair now recall that in
our second example
you got three times as much as I did
okay but the
is not just more than fair to you as it
would appear to anyone it's more than
fair to me too
why well first why is it more than fair
to you you put in 10 you sacrifice 10
and you get back 12 okay but I put in 2
and I get back for my the fairness
outcome standard this is obviously more
than fair think about it this way it's
impossible to make an outcome more equal
than equal but it's not impossible to
make an outcome better than equal
suppose I offer you the following deal
you give me a $5 bill I'll give you a $5
bill is that equal sure is that unfair
no is it fair yeah is it stupid
sure
now suppose I said hey you know what
this is just kind of boring I got a new
idea you give me a five and then I'll
give you a ten and we'll just do that as
long as you want now if we do that the
outcome for you is indisputably more
than fair it's better than equal and if
equals fair more better than equal has
to be more than fair
it's just simple logic so here's the key
idea capitalism lets everyone take more
out than they put into the system all at
the same time because of the positive
some nature of cooperative transactions
so at every step along the way the whole
is always equally more than the sum of
the parts this is a beautiful thing and
the key thing is to remember it's all
about voluntary transactions often
people will say oh I I believe in Adam
Smith I get it yeah you'll have a more
prosperous society if you have free
trade bla bla bla bla but that still
doesn't explain that till doesn't assure
us that rich people don't end up being
rich at the expense of poor people and
it's true if you don't read Adam Smith
very very carefully you can reach that
conclusion quite easily but you have to
remember we only allow voluntary
transaction so that means that every one
of those margins you have to make the
other person better off you have no
choice because he doesn't have to
transact with you so this is not a
result that's just true in the aggregate
it's also true at the most micro level
add it up it's also consistent with over
a century of evidence from around the
world
I mean clearly it's much better to be a
poor person say the median person in the
lowest quintile of a thriving capitalist
society than it is to be an average
person in a centrally plan society we
know this this is there's no need to
cite statistics this is just so obvious
so why is this so hard to see if the
logic is so clear and the evidence is so
clear why is this hard to see well as I
mentioned earlier social justice tears
leave out half the outcome story they
leave out the inputs that make the
output possible
another reason why this is so hard to
see is that most people have no idea
where goods and services come from they
have no idea how we end up with a GDP
they have no theory of GDP determination
at all
nothing so as a result they do the only
thing they can do they don't consciously
choose to do this but just think about
it if you have absolutely no theory for
where output comes from you have to
assume that it's fixed you have to
assume that it's effectively manna from
heaven you have no choice what else you
get
what else you gonna assume well if you
assume that output is effectively manna
from heaven then that means it's going
to fall no matter what any of us of us
do there's no meaningful differences in
opportunity cost across thus and
whatever our actions are will not affect
the total output in that case the
division of the output is fundamentally
a zero-sum game so if I get more you or
somebody else has to get less now in
such a world where output is in fact
manna from heaven
it is indeed impossible for everyone to
get more out than they put in all at the
same time in fact it's total nonsense in
fantasy but this is the exact logical
frame that most people have luckily
that's not the case for capitalism true
honest capitalism is positively abuzz
with positive some cooperative activity
cooperative surpluses that impel
voluntary transactions make it possible
for everyone to get more out than they
put in at every single step it away so
with capitalism everyone can get more
out much more out than they put in all
at the same time so capitalism isn't
just fair as a process is also fair as
outcome indeed it's more than fair to
everyone any way you slice it thank you
thank you David
I have a great new take away I'm gonna
steal from you
manna from heaven economics our next
speaker George I eat a his president of
the free Africa Foundation which
established in 1993 in Washington DC to
serve as a catalyst for change in Africa
the foundation actively promotes
political economic and intellectual
freedom and has popularized the
statement that Africa is poor because
she is not free dr. I eat a has taught
at American University Wayne State
College in Nebraska and Bloomsburg
University in Pennsylvania he's also
been a national fellow at the Hoover
Institution and a resident scholar at
the Heritage Foundation he's an author
and has written several 'high several
highly acclaimed books on Africa
including Africa betray'd which won the
HL Mencken award he's widely quoted in
newspapers and as a guest on many TV and
radio programs and I might mention our
poverty cure program that Acton
Institute is produced and many of the
scholars here have received you're one
of the stars in that so we knew you when
he's a native of Ghana West Africa he
earned his master's degree in economics
at the University of Western Ontario and
his PhD from the University of Manitoba
in 1981 please join me in welcoming dr.
Anita
first of all I'd like to thank Anita
Wilson and also Chris for inviting me to
speak to you at this forum and I also
would like to thank you for finding some
time to come and listen to me and I was
listening to David roe
when he was talking about capitalism but
capitalism is a dirty word in Africa it
is a way which I wouldn't you know very
much hesitate to push in Africa
why because after independence from
colonial rule African leaders argued
that seed amid one money mentos a
logistic error
they argue that colonialism was evil and
exploitative
and because the colonial is where
capital is a half it meant that
capitalism too was evil and exploitative
and therefore they were going to adopt
socialism as their guiding ideology but
he didn't even understand socialism so
how much more can they promote
capitalism see they the type of
socialism the practice was a peculiar
form of Swiss bank socialism which a lot
ahead of Sid and his cohort of Ministers
to rip and plunder Africa's you know
treasures for deposit in Switzerland a
cabinet minister in Mugabe's government
was asked to define socialism and he
said here in Zimbabwe socialism means
that what is mine is mine but what is
yours we share
don't ask him to define capitalism
because we see him Bobby capitalism
means what his mind is mine but what is
yours I take with interest
now the Santos is been a president of
Angola for more than 34 years he was
spinner he has been a Marxist dictator
of Angola now all of a sudden he says
that primitive capital accumulation is
good for Africa naturally his daughter
Isabella it's not the youngest woman
below near in Africa now the hypocrisy
of African leaders and the chick Henri
of the ruling elites now what has
brought Africa down there are 55 African
countries and most of them are not doing
well that's why the immense mineral
wealth of the continent I mean you name
the mineral and you find it in Africa
gold diamonds palladium they are there
in Africa but that's why the mineral
world the vast majority of the African
people I see mired in poverty abject
poverty economic stagnation and
deprivation if I the United Nations
estimated that F at a current rate of
economic growth or progress it would
take Africa 150 years before it
satisfies the Millennium Development
Goals that's why the united mission says
and also the World Bank back in 2008
determined that the number of people
living in poverty in Africa hasn't
really changed much the past 20 years
more than half of Africans live in
poverty
after 55 African countries fewer than 10
can be called economic success stories
and fewer so have an independent and
free press back in 1990 only four
African countries where democratic today
23 years later to 18 so in other ways
it's taken us 23 years to add nine more
democracies at this rate it would take
Africa more than a century to become
fully democratic now there are some of
us who are very angry angry at the
condition of Africa things should never
have turned out this way now Africa has
more dictators per capita than any other
continent and get this no dictator has
brought lasting prosperity to any
African country and I tell you what
there's no such thing as a benevolent
dictator
the only good dictator is a dead one
there are so many people who want to
help Africa it's noble to help Africa of
course you know it's is part of our
Christian impulse to help we are
fortunate but there are certain pitfalls
that we must avoid right now there's a
lot of buzz about Africa here Africa
rising up against the fastest-growing
continent this real or hyper much of it
is hype and it is something that we
shall avoid and you see this is the
favorite gambit of the World Bank and
wasting donors see they have pumped more
than 600 billion into Africa since 1960
with little show for it so they're
desperate for a success story even small
baby steps I hailed a giant strides now
remember the coast in the early 1990s
ibecause was hailed as an economic
miracle what happened in 2000 and 2005
descended into brutal civil war my own
country Ghana is also touted as an
economic success story but now the
country is broke and even faced the
International bond rating companies
lowered gannets bond rating from a B+ to
a B and the country's total national
debt is 50% of its GDP then I was you
g'nite was also held by western donors
as an economic success story what
happened this is changed now it's
president back in 1986 said no African
leaders should be in power for more than
20 years he's still there
then we had Egypt to Mesa they were all
healed as an economic success stories
but now now secondly sure Africa is
great very rapidly but we have to make a
distinction between economic growth and
economic development the two are not the
same thing again how the economic growth
without the development
tomorrow fight this was the case of
Angola in Nigeria in 2008 and Ghoulies
economy expanded at a phenomenal rate of
twenty point eight percent but today 60%
of Angolans live in poverty is the same
in Nigeria I'm not saying that a no
economic success stories in Africa there
are but a few and even then those
country's economic success stories like
Rwanda Ethiopia Ghana they mean they are
small countries they don't have the
locomotive heft to pull the rest of the
continent out of its economic - one sure
Africa is growing but the growth is not
internally generated the recent growth
that you saying it's coming from a
commodity boom boom in commodity prices
and also trade with China that has
pushed Africa's economic growth to 5.1
percent which the World Bank and the IMF
are saying now the second pitfall if you
want help Africa is to shed political
correctness
there are many Americans who do not want
to criticize black African leaders for
fear that divin be labeled racist so -
are we from criticisms but Africans
themselves know that we are part at a
strophic leadership failure in Africa
now since 1960 we have had hardly 227
half
and heads of state challenge anybody to
name you 20 good leaders and they won't
be able to come up with 20 good leaders
out of the two to seven even if they can
name you 20 it means that the vast
majority of the leadership were utter
failures Africans notice the slate of
the post-colonial leadership has been an
assortment of Swiss bank socialists
Jaguar maxes what revolutionaries
crocodile liberators have briefcase
bandits Africans themselves know this so
no political correctness Africans simply
want you to talk straight to them the
fair pitfall is that for far too long
Western Westerners and Western leaders
and donors have embraced African leaders
the charisma of African leaders and
their rhetoric as well as like anybody
who comes to Washington DC and
professors reserved to be anti-communist
suddenly opens up the floodgates of
Western aid and as a matter of fact
these leaders and I'm sorry to say this
they are crafty and you have played the
West for a sucker and they have been
extracted billions and billions in aid
row back in 1998 President Clinton
visited Africa a hail the leaders of
Ethiopia Eritrea Rwanda Uganda Congo as
the new leaders of Africa taking charge
of their own backyard what happened
barely six months after Clinton returned
to the u.s. ethiopia and eritrea were at
war
an arrest of the so called new leaders
we're at each other's throat in Congo
swore and it's not a leadership that is
important which we save Africa focus on
the institution's look Africa had its
own market institutions before the
colonial is arrived there were free
markets in Africa free trade and free
enterprise in Africa that is what needs
to be rebuilt in Africa not the rhetoric
of these leaders the fourth pitfall that
we should recognize is that government
is the problem in Africa not a solution
Africans themselves know what ails them
as a matter of fact one traditional
chief said this here in Lesotho we got
two problems rats and the government
but somehow Weston donors and Weston you
know the IMF and war bank they have this
abiding faith that become work with
these governments African governments
form partnerships with them even bribed
them catch old and persuade them to
reform the abominable systems tomorrow
fact you know back in 1981 the World
Bank came up with a structural I just
went program the structural adjustment
program was that economic reform program
and put up 25 billion dollars to help
African countries move away from state
dominated economies to market these
economies the wall bank tried to
persuade 29 African countries just what
happened they took the money and did the
Babangida boogie
once there for three steps back a flip
minute cake sidekick : on the fat Swiss
bank account much ado about nothing
after one decade 1981 to 1991 the World
Bank funded out of the 29 iJustine
countries only six of them were
successful but even then those six where
the Gandia Burkina Faso Ghana Nigeria
Tanzania and Zimbabwe but then within
two years most most of those countries
are not successfully they are vanished
so it was a phantom list of success
stories now there is something that we
need to get straight the ruling elites
are simply not interested in reform
period ask them to develop the economies
and they'll develop their pocket
ask them to seek foreign investment and
they will seek a foreign country to
invest their loot ask them to cut
government spending and it was set up a
Ministry of less government spending
Chardin the good governance is good for
a country and Tanzania set up a Ministry
of good governance Ghana was told to
prepare to place more reliance on the
private sector and gonna set up a
Ministry of private-sector development
please don't tell them that free markets
will help Africa because you will see a
Ministry of what
now there is something else which is you
know a new threat which has come up and
that is African governments have grown
so bloated that they are now suffocating
their economies they are preach free
market see all capitalist now but on the
other hand they're doing everything
through their policies to kill the
private sector
hey Ghana Ghana country of 95 million
has 97 cabinet and deputy ministers 97
kenya has 94 zimbabwe 78 the US with the
population of 320 million has you know
for the secretaries and assistant
secretaries now in Ghana let me take
Nigeria face a Nigerian senator salaries
and the clean furniture allowance travel
allowance entertainment allowance all
those allowances if he Adam them to
their to their salaries they take home a
coup two million dollars a year in a
country where 60% of the people are poor
now in Kenya the average salary and
allowances King and MP gets it's more
than 350,000 dollars which is more than
what President Obama is feed and again
allowances in you know you get this
Canyon empties say that you know the
roots and I would be are so bad that
when did travel on the routes through
Parliament it shakes their bottom small
and so they want to rough road allowance
in Ghana of the 97 ministers and cabinet
ministers each one of them wants to have
the government bandulu or a house and
then in addition it wants an SUV a
saloon car a driver
coke a gardener a night watchman a day
watchman and so forth now according to a
point where last week I was in Ghana and
I held a press conference Hannah the
government about the size of this
bloated bureaucracy I was on November
7th and on November 8th the state-owned
newspaper called The Daily Graphic put
me on their front page and yes this is
reduce government the size of government
in other words it's a small victory but
like I said Africans want street talk
and this straight talk is beginning to
penetrate even in my own country thank
you very much
thank you George that was so nuanced it
was hard to find a takeaway but but I'm
gonna go with the two problems rats and
government okay our next panelist is at
Knoll he's the chair of the department
of economics at Westmont College his
most recent publications include
reckoning with markets more with moral
reflection in economics and human
flourishing the moral and economic case
for economic growth his scholarship on
the just wage in scholastic and
Reformation economic thought economic
institutions in first century Roman
Palestine and Adam Smith economics has
been published in the Journal of X
of the history of economic thought faith
in economics history of political
economy and the Journal of markets and
morality dr. Noel serves on the
Editorial Board of faith and economics
the journal sponsored by the Association
of Christian economists
his current research focuses on the
evolution of Christian conceptions of
usury the just price and legitimate
economic gain for a book series entitled
reclaiming the intellectual the
Christian intellectual tradition next
spring dr. noha will be a visiting
faculty scholar at Duke University
please join me in welcoming dr. Noel
well I want to thank Anita Folsom in the
free market forum for this opportunity
to address the subject of capitalism and
Christian ethics we've witnessed over
the past quarter century the collapse of
centrally planned economies in Eastern
Europe the implosion of the Soviet Union
and the adoption of market reforms in
China India and elsewhere these events
along with the great the recent global
financial crisis have spurred
theological reflection on capitalism
while some Christian scholars celebrate
its moral underpinnings many others
doubt they exist or debate their
validity and of course modern capitalism
has been the subject of scorn but those
who are not theologians here we have
representative capitalism's alleged
perverse effects on civil society in
this political scientists work consumed
how markets corrupt children in
fertilized adults in swaddle citizens
whole let's see going much further we
have caricatures of capitalism as
depicted in this representation of the
anticipated outcome of a wider free
trade zone in the Americas and candidly
I could spend my whole time commenting
on this a particular character for
globalization uber alles globalization
above everything
I'm resist the temptation to come in on
my home state of Texas where I live now
in California or even Canada here but
more seriously though there have been
criticisms of capitalism leveled that
suggest it's an impersonal economic
system that overlooks the needs of the
poor so the Christian philosopher Kant
Van Til declares the poor don't have the
ability to pay the price asked by the
market hence the market doesn't respond
to their needs but only satisfies the
wants of those with sufficient income
what are we to make of this particular
critique and other related challenges we
want to treat them fairly without
caricature house capitalism in
valuing light of Christian ethics I'll
offer this morning a qualified positive
evaluation of capitalism on the basis of
Christian values in 20 minutes I'll
limit my evaluation mainly to those
features of the ongoing debate related
to capitalism and poverty the subject of
this panel I'll draw in Holy Scripture
and the tradition of Christian teaching
on economic matters from my sources
please note that for times sake I won't
provide all of the specific references
and instead encourage you to find them
in my paper on the Hillsdale website
written in the ancient Mediterranean
world the Bible clearly predates
capitalism and offers no blueprint for
any particular economic system yet the
principles God directs ancient Israel to
organize their economic activity around
in the Pentateuch wisdom and prophetic
literature reflect uniquely godly values
for economic institutions in the New
Testament we find Jesus expanding on
these values even as market related
institutions slowly begins to be
manifested in first century Palestine by
the time that the earliest form of
capitalism arrives in Europe in the 14th
and 15th centuries with the commercial
revolution double-entry bookkeeping
Bills of exchange a commercial
capitalism there's a burgeoning to a
body of Christian moral reflection on
the marketplace going on later with the
Industrial Revolution industrial
capitalism frost Intelligence popes
through encyclicals and Orthodox
scholars have continued to search for
the appropriate moral language to
evaluate the dynamics of capitalism
modern capitalism is certainly no less
deserving of scrutiny by Christians and
I attempt to contribute to that dialogue
here with certain significant caveat in
place which I'll name again I find
capitalism largely compatible with
Christian ethics capitalism understood
first off now as relying upon the
institutions of private property rights
open competitive market exchanges
grounded in voluntary transactions
occupational freedom and the rule of law
to oversee these institutions these
institutions matter since they're the
rules of the game the structure economic
incentives when the rules of the game
change the economic incentives change
accordingly and that of course can give
rise to different forms of modern
capitalism state capitalism mr. Nando de
Soto reminds us on the rise in many
parts of the world where their security
property rights is absent and we're poor
entrepreneurs don't have collateral to
enable them to obtain credit there they
can't rely upon the rule of law to
enforce contracts as they move into the
extra legal sector and product
innovations key to driving economic
growth under capitalism language a
language and mixed capitalism where
government intervenes in the form of
tariffs licenses or subsidies again the
rules of the game are different there
and we want to keep in mind the
differences between free-market
capitalism and other forms now let's
move to Christian economic ethics and we
I suggest they begin with God's creative
activity Genesis 1 through 2 describes
God's creative activity and fashioning
the earth and its bounty of life in
declaring it six times in Genesis 1 that
the creation is good God affirms the
value of the material world he is the
ultimate owner wherever we have a task
as creatures made in God's image to
combine the resources given to us to
create value this is often identified as
the creation mandate to rule and subdue
the earth that God owns that is we
follow God in His initiative and
creativity to make the earth productive
as God stewart's the first stewardship
task of keeping the garden reflects a
vision of delight and flourishing and
producing value that by all evidence is
God's design and creation even after the
fall into sin Genesis 4 provides
examples of creative innovation with the
fashioning of tools building of cities
an expression of music and the arts and
some Genesis offers a vision of creating
value added that's associated with human
flourishing and makes the positive
judeo-christian perspective on wealth
creation essentially unique among all
other world religions so what are the
implications of this creation man day
for Christian economic ethics I'll name
a few here first the scriptures affirm
the validity of private property rights
for both tangible and intangible
property this human connection of
property
it's both Michael Novak and Robert
Sirico point out is not merely about
control over physical things rather it's
tied up with a person's capacity to
apply his intellect to matter and ideas
to look ahead to plan and steward the
use of that possession human ingenuity
the commandment against theft and the
Decalogue the Ten Commandments and the
statements forbidding the movement of a
neighbor's boundary marker indicate the
significance of private property rights
it's evident that property rights were
transferable in the biblical world this
is suggested by directions in the Book
of Leviticus to sellers and buyers to
pay fair prices
there's also archaeological evidence of
sellers price lists in the ancient Near
East we've heard from Dave Rose about
market transactions grounded voluntary
exchange creating a positive sum game
interestingly in the book of Proverbs
for the wisdom literature there's an
affirmation of the honor associated with
legitimate profits where ill-gotten
gains are said to be of no value
deceptive game brings death
honorable gained brings life secondly a
crucial form in which the responsible
steward acts is in the pursuit of
entrepreneurial initiatives to create
value in the face of limited knowledge
such initiatives require a large measure
of economic freedom entrepreneurial
initiatives of course are a key element
in the dynamic nature of capitalism
human plans to initiate ways to create
wealth inherently face uncertainty God
alone is omniscient prospective demand
and cost conditions are unknown the wise
steward counts the cost as Jesus tells
us in Luke chapter 14 this inherently
involves a subjective forecast of the
economic conditions drawn up under the
constraint of creaturely limitations hi
can Bob Mises her right to emphasize
that any entrepreneur must make a
calculation of cost than his prospect of
anticipating cost associated with
decisions and not merely account for
costs associated with events as Alfred
Marshall posits Frank Knight highlights
the distinction nature of risk when
decisions are made with known
probabilities risk is inherently part of
the entrepreneurial process
in the matthean parable of the talents
Matthew 25 Jesus portrays the master as
commending the risk-takers among his
servants and condemning those who buried
their talents from the ground now it's
granted that in context this is a
parable told to affirm the responsible
use of spiritual gifts but I think it's
significant that Jesus draws on everyday
first century Palestine in life to make
its point and doesn't condemn
risk-taking thirdly scripture places a
key emphasis on one's obligation as a
private property owner each Israelite is
expected to practice reciprocity
indicating another when one suffers
economically due to a drought or a flood
interest-free lows are offered loans
would be repaid at agricultural produce
out of the subsequent harvest there is
the provision of gleanings for the
able-bodied poor in the harvests of once
filled by the proper lists that is the
widow the orphan and the Sojourner it's
worthy of note here that the poor also
takes some measure of responsibility by
being engaged in addressing their
property problem as gling and the
difficult to harvest portion of the
fields involved hard work think here of
the proverbs 31 woman she buys a field
she further invests her earnings and
planning a vineyard but what else do we
read she opens her arms to the poor and
extends her hands to the needy fourthly
God's gifting of humans is manifested a
dispersal of talent differing skills and
abilities lead to the need for
specialization and trade individuals
groups and nations find their
comparative advantage and of course
their comparative disadvantage as well
the dispersal of nations in Genesis 11
upon the leveling of the Tower of Babel
has economic implications as each group
finds a different endowment of resources
the Church Fathers observe the benefits
of this disposal trade around the
ancient Mediterranean world they see
trade ultimately bonding nations
together again and I'll mention modern
Christian e-commerce picking up on this
theme I recommend Dan Penn's new book on
a Christian economic ethics that passe
demonstrates how global North countries
in fact benefit the global South
countries through trade higher wages
and so forth but the dispersal of
talents is bound to create income
inequalities rising gaps and income are
interpreted by some Christian critics of
capitalism as inherently unacceptable
Jim Wallis puts it bluntly
God hates inequality referring to income
inequality in truth the picture is not
that simple
it's been pointed out it's much more
accurate to say that God hates injustice
and oppression which both produce and
exacerbate inequality as I'll try to
show when considering the context of the
prophetic challenges laid on ancient
Israel so the Scriptures affirm that
those with more means are responsible to
care for those much less well-off but
they don't call for direct efforts to
lessen income inequality addressing
poverty and remedying income inequality
are not equivalent tasks and I'm
referring the paper to my colleague PJ
Hills good prints paper that's I think
marvelous on this score fifthly
individuals and families must be enabled
with the minimum resources needed to
pursue their stewardship tasks and to
flourished and so just real briefly this
is what the division of the land is all
about in Joshua where each tribe
receives a portion of the land a key
resource in an agrarian economy unit
clearly varies in its air ability and
fertility of soil the families are
responsible for the use of these
resources this undermines the notion of
communal natural national resources as
somehow God's will for an economic
system and again implies the need for
private property rights the Jubilee in
the end is about an economic dignity
being restored the household where after
50 years their land comes back to them
we might think of an analogy today in
our modern service based economy of the
need for provision of education and the
building of human capital for each
families of baseline and provision the
details of course of how such mechanisms
might be established today are not
spelled out in the biblical record but
the essential principle of obligation to
the less fortunate remains then we
discussed how an economic system must
account for fallen human nature and
their numerous implications here
first off stewardship can be twisted
into the singular pursuit of wealth
accumulation biblical warnings regarding
the perils of wealth
obviously predate capitalism Jesus warns
of the spiritual hazards of possessions
telling his disciples not to build
possessions on earth nor to serve Mammon
build treasures on earth in their
exegesis of Jesus teaching on wealth and
the synoptic Gospels the patristic cent
elastics build a theological case
against avarice it's true that we find
some degree of hostility towards wealth
and commerce in the patristic era
cerebral the church followers followed
ancient Mediterranean thinking expressed
on the notion that since the sum total
of humanity's wealth is a fixed amount a
game by one person must necessarily come
at another's expense oftentimes this led
to a hostility towards the rich who were
seeing the gain at the expense of the
poor by seeing the seizing their land or
charging them interest on alone secondly
sin can corrupt economic transactions
I've touched on the argument that human
creativity and free markets tend to
flourish and tandem entrepreneurial
activity allows others to share in that
creativity the response launched manure
must carefully regard the needs of
others in creating value their
self-interest is checked by both
competition and conscience conscience
can constrain competitors for even
though we're fallen creatures sin is not
erased the image of God in each of us
according to the Apostle James
nevertheless economic transactions can
involve fraud deceit or some element of
economic coercion we observed in the
scriptures reneging on loans is
condemned just prices and exchange must
occur workers wages are not to be
arbitrarily withheld false weights and
balances are not to be utilized for
transaction thinking about the ladder
through misleading wizard measures of
weight consumers of food and other
necessities might be overcharged and
farmers might be underpaid for their
produce by wholesalers now as my fellow
panelists David roses emphasized
opportunism is a kind of implicit cost
that can be associated with market
behavior but this most often occurs
where there are
rules of the game opener one party is
able to take advantage of at access to
government to move the rules in their
favor so thirdly economic life in a
fallen world can be characterized by
economic participants seeking to gain
economic power over others in
accumulating property or raising their
incomes often such power only endures
through government backing of their
efforts which we speak of as rent
seeking activity this seems to be
recognized by the Old Testament prophets
consider how the prophet Isaiah rebukes
the adding of house to house or field
the field or how the Prophet Habakkuk
speaks against those who gain and justly
for their house biblical scholars
suggest that these actions likely refer
to gains obtained but the family of the
king along with his political advisors
and military leaders who obtain their
gains through unjust rulings of Kings or
earlier pre monarchy through that of the
judges similarly in first century Roman
Palestine we find John the Baptist's and
Jesus each facing economic power wielded
over others but those associated with
the Roman Empire
when these parties come to be baptized
by John such as the tax collectors he
tells them collect no more than you're
authorized to do and he says to the
Roman soldiers who want to be baptized
do not extort money from anyone by
threats or by false accusation in Luke 3
similarly Jesus came in Zacchaeus the
chief tax collector for making a 4-fold
restitution of those whom he's defrauded
the notion of a zero-sum economic world
that sometimes alluded to in the New
Testament Gospels reflects a widespread
perception that the wealthy accrued land
through favors offered by Herod the
Tetrarch of Galilee or through
collecting taxes in a capricious manner
from peasant farmers fourthly the
problem of limited knowledge is
exacerbated by the fall we know that
each person has specific knowledge
regarding their own skills resources and
opportunity cost knowledge not
obtainable by government planners so
they shouldn't be enabled with this
power they may have good intentions
these lead to harmful consequences so
the public choice literature tells us
and the market-based alternative is have
economic decisions made across the
entire economic system by countless
agents who have specialized particular
knowledge relative to their own
preferences and their technology they
have the prices are resources that flow
from such decisions face open market
competition in a capitalist system this
also acts to disperse power Nash
observes one of the more effective ways
of mitigating the effects of human sin
in society is dispersing and
decentralizing power through free-market
social arrangements and then the
treatment of the marginalized a critical
consideration in crucial economic ethics
those who are sometimes named as the
poor and the needy are spoken of as the
widow orphan and Sojourner mosaic laws
requiring gleaning for the poor in
interest-free loans reflect the concern
for those at the margin it's not really
though to provide sustenance given the
Scriptures high view of personal
economic agency the goal is to assist
them to begin again to help themselves
and so to regain their dignity again
this is where the goal of human
flourishing matters poverty reduction
has a greater way in the scripture
because it propels people forward on
their stewardship journey of wealth
creation by the way I'm not offering
here a version of the health and wealth
gospel scripture clearly recognizes that
a follower of God may struggle with
poverty they are not poor because they
lack faith and the faithful do not
always become wealthy in the few
instances where government actions is
connected to the poor it involves
addressing economic injustice
so in Psalm 72 the king is said to be
responsible to do justice for the poor
this is not specifically a duty to feed
and clothe all the poor but rather to
deliver them from economic impression
Israel's rulers were to ensure that the
poor were rightly treated this concern
for the poor is reflected in the benefit
of capitalism and economic growth and in
Adam Smith recognizes this when he
speaks of how no society can be
flourishing in which the majority of its
members are poor and miserable
for many commentators Smith highlights
the moral structure of capitalism in our
book on economic growth that was
mentioned with myself Stephen Smith not
Adam Smith but and Bruce well it has
more data on that and for times sake
I'll refer to that for that data so I
just wrap up here by saying my qualified
endorsement of capitalism really is one
that says let's be careful to not adopt
capitalism as an ism and come close to
deifying it it has tremendous wealth
creating powers in many ways it's
compatible with Christian values but we
shouldn't attach such significance to
capitalism and its wealth creating
abilities that it replaces our sense of
God's omnipotence nor should we endorse
any particular economic outcome is
righteous that is being beyond question
as long as it's the product of free
market forces the institutions of free
market capitalism deserve to be lauded
only if we reserve the highest praise
for our Creator the ultimate eternal
source of all good things thank you
thank you doctor no we're far too far
too many religious leaders seem to
suggest that capitalism somehow
fundamentally immoral and what I
appreciate about your presentation is
that it reminds us that the Jewish and
Christian scriptures well not advocating
a particular economic system do clearly
embrace free market fundamentals such as
the legitimacy private property and
profit so thank you for reminding us of
those points we do have about 20 minutes
left for questions and answers and I do
ask you to raise your hand and
microphone will come to you and if you
would please limit your preambles we
will get more questions in thank you
first one here
my name is qua I'm from a studying
college Kansas and my area my field of
study is in urban planning and real
estate development in economics I asked
my student every time in a class
anywhere always to ask questions some
let us set an example here I got a
question I want to pose to y'all a lot
of times when we talk about economic
development and we say that property
rights is one of the major things and I
agree with that but a lot of us don't
talk about property rights in this sense
property rights involve a fee simple and
leasehold a lot of times when you're an
attorney you want to turn property
rights and say that hey we'll give you
the land that is very very very
difficult because of traditions and
everything now in Singapore in China I
was born and raised in Singapore but
live in the States for the last 30 years
in Singapore for example you can have
property rights you can have a leasehold
my mother-in-law right now live in
apartment which is a leasehold for 99
years she can sell that leasehold and
she's son my leasehold is worth more
than a quarter million dollar in u.s.
1400 square feet of space I'm saying
that even people like Hernandez a de
Soto eminent development economist again
when they tell her property rights they
are always thinking in terms of sympathy
now we need to talk about leasehold it
make it easier for people to have that
right and develop that with that lease
hole and develop new something very very
fruitful you see that a lot in Singapore
especially in China all right and my
question is what are your thing about
this concept of property rights in terms
of lease hole okay so free market
economists give short shrift to to
anything outside of absolute ownership
any responses from our panelists David I
think that's a great point and I've been
a big fan of Singapore's
situation in fact I did some papers a
year a number of years ago on economic
development in China and one of the
things that my co-author and I had to
face up to was what we called the Lee
Kuan Yew problem and we could we
considered it a problem because
conventional wisdom at the time was that
democracy was kind of a de facto
necessary condition for a thriving
capitalist society and yet Lee Kuan Yew
kind of ruined that story well if you
think about economic history further
back of the rise of free market
institutions and capitalism don't occur
under democracy they occur mostly under
monarchies in early Europe so what was
what's really really important is
confidence by ordinary people in the
rules of the game when they have that
that allows competition to run wild it
under under some constraints of course
but run wild in a positive kind of way
and I think that that's what someone
like a Lee Kuan Yew or a king in England
or whatever can bring to the table at
some point and so I think that that's
that's a terrific point I agree with
completely IDI
well I I think it's very interesting
point Lee Kuan Yew in many ways was a
model for dong-chil paying he don't
shopping visited Singapore late 1970s
and implement reforms of leasing land
back to Chinese farmers in the early
1980s and following output tremendously
exploded when Chinese farmers didn't
have to produce everything for the state
but could produce for themselves and
sell that as well in 2007 the Chinese
government began to open up property
rights and extend their length they've
just recently moved that way as well
it'd be interesting study I think there
is a important not just correlation with
causation going there is expanding the
rights under leasing to property and
expanding output in production so I
think there's some what are you there
all right we have a question in the
front here
this is from mr. I eat a President Bush
instituted what I believe called the
millennium fund and I was wondering how
you would compare that with past
development funds and how it is doing
presently there are part of the pitfalls
and he attempts to aid Africa and I
remember that you know before Bush
President Clinton set up Agora the
African growth and opportunity Act you
know saying that well look you know if
if African governments reform the
economies and did this and that you know
the u.s. would throw up in the air its
market to African goods and so forth
very very very few countries sort of
benefited from that you know one country
was Lisu to and then it was also another
country like Tanzania and when Bush came
to power he set up the Millennium
Development Challenge account and that
was even more stringent and there were
three criteria those African governments
that govern justly and also invested in
education in their people and also
promoted economic freedom will be
eligible for grants I get this grants
grant means that they were not going to
be paid back no the requirements and
benchmarks and conditions were so
stringent that no African country sort
of qualified so just what in 2003 in
2003 in 2006 the Bush administration
gave Tanzania 11 million dollars to help
it qualify
for a grant okay okay you know a subset
of money and you know implemented reform
in audits and zinnia do into February
2006 push one on the trip to Tanzania
and when he got there he found that the
entire cabinet in the government had
resigned over a corruption scandal and
then get this the anti-corruption za
call Edward who SIA he himself was
implicated in a corruption scandal of
himself so that was what happened to the
bush you know millennium developed sorry
Millennium Challenge account you know it
didn't succeed right here in front so
how does the free world help Africa how
what should they do well this is a tough
food well it's first of all like I said
you know the pitfalls that I you know
indicated no more one you know avoid
hype you know number two love [ __ ]
political correctness
you know Africans know exactly what's
wrong with their continent okay number
three you know pay more attention to the
institutions institutions that critical
institutions such as the media the
judiciary they let for Commission and so
forth and forget about government the
government is the problem
and also the fifth one which I should
didn't have time to mention was that you
know if you want to help you know you
have to make up your mind
whom do you want to help the government
or the people now African economy is
divided into three sectors as a modern
sector there is a traditional sector and
then stuck in between is informal sector
the modern sector is the abode of the
ruling vampire elites that's what I call
them
and then you know the vast majority of
the African people you can find them in
the informal and the traditional sectors
if you want to help the poor people of
Africa go into the informal and the
traditional sectors now institutions
institutions institutions that's what
needs to help Africa as modified in
March of 2009 Barack Obama was in Africa
it came to Ghana al-jannah was the face
you know country that he visit and he
says something which I've been saying
all along and that was that he says
Africa doesn't need strong leaders
Africa needs strong institutions now me
to me the best gift Americans can give
to Africa is a free and independent
media so that Africans themselves can
speak out and debate solid debate
solutions for their own problems look
they have thrown me in jail in Senegal
security agents raided my hotel room in
Nairobi even Washington I wasn't safe my
office was firebombed ok now in March of
2000 and March of 2009 I met Hillary
that's the Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton he was to go on a night mission
tour of Africa and collect you know he
assembled a few African experts to ask
them to pick their brains in terms of
what you do now when he got to my turn I
told her that look you don't need to
reinvent the wheel remember the former
Soviet Union
now what led to the collapse of the
former Soviet Union okay now what led to
the collapse of the former Soviet Union
was really free Europe what Africa needs
Radio Free Africa and you know she
thought about that he said that's a good
idea
never had much about that
so the Venice you know the point that I
want to emphasize again and again and
again is that it is Africans who have to
solve their own problems
and they need to have the freedom and
the media to discuss their problems and
solutions to the earth to solutions to
their problems
now reform which is internally generated
is far more sustainable than reform
which is dictated from the outside and
that is why you know I have constantly
been preaching African solutions for
African problems it doesn't mean that
Americans shouldn't help Americans can
help by the hub you know support the
solutions that Africans themselves have
created is crafted to solve their own
problems good morning and thank you very
much my name is Don rocker I'm president
of Public Interest Institute in Mount
Pleasant Iowa it's a free market limited
government traditional values think-tank
the problem as I go around in Iowa and
talk to average people is they think
that capitalism is immoral now the
hundreds of us in this room have been
persuaded otherwise by your eloquent
presentations this morning and maybe
even thousands will be persuaded by
seeing the reprint from the videotape on
the Hillsdale website but most people
get their information from the mass
media which is full of bubble heads who
think that well they have no knowledge
of economics and even less of faith and
so my ask my question to you is how do
we overcome that relentless pounding of
the crap such as Barbara puts out that
was illustrated in dr. Knowles slide
that we are not on the side of the
angels I'd like to take a crack at that
if I might one of the problems that we
have in our society is people who vote
often don't know much about anything
and they particularly don't know much
about economics and that's nothing new
in saying that many people have said
that before but I think the problem is
even deeper than that I think the way
economists teach economics is a very
counterproductive there's an object to
our study it's called the economy the
economy has a history it's a real thing
if you go back in human history it's a
fairly simple thing as time goes on it
gets more complex and there's more
competitive variance it only stands the
reasons that a young person's ability to
understand economics will be greater the
further back in history you try to study
the economy in my view we should start
teaching children at first second grade
about the very very simple concepts of
gains from cooperation like we talked
about today you couldn't get simpler
gains from exchange which has a very
similar mathematical structure and then
you build up with that complementing it
with actual economic history so that
several years down the road they're
starting to talk about things like
supply and demand and market pricing and
so on and so forth the way we teach
economics now overwhelmingly is we love
our tools and as Ronald Coase likes to
say we like our graphs because it gives
us something to do and so we organize
our classes around throwing a bunch of
tools at people and it's fun to do and
so on and so forth we don't really think
about the fact that there's some kind of
an ultimate objective to what we're
doing we're supposed to be learning
about the economy you got to learn about
the thing as a whole and you got to
learn about the parts so we have macaron
we have micro but we've gotten away from
that and I don't know where ever there
but certainly since the neoclassical
revolution they've been too far from
that so I think what we need is a
revolution at k-12 education we need to
stop conceding the battle until it's too
late by the time we get students at 18
19 years old they've had social justice
Theory drummed in that her
it's continuously for 12 years so now
we're fighting a pill those are easy
ideas for the brain to understand
because they comport with our natural
moral sensibilities so people who are
advocates of those positions really have
a huge advantage they're basically just
asking people to indulge their atavisms
our job is much much much harder the
institutions of a large free-market
society are extremely complex they're
invented and they're abstract so there's
no particular reason for us to find them
easy to understand coming from Africa
where there's so much hostility against
capitalism I tell you how I deal with it
you know nah man the first thing is I
point out to my students that there are
two definitions of capitalism there is a
am axion definition of capitalism and
there max is define capitalism as a
system which is based upon the
exploitation of labor
now that type of definition has really
really gained currency in the third
world you know also in the Communist
world okay whereas you know any
economist would tell you that capitalism
is simply a system in which you know in
private individuals of the economic
problems of what to produce foam and you
know how now the second way by which I
deal with it is to tell anybody who asks
me about capitalism that there are
various forms of capitalism Japanese
capitalism is not the same as American
capitalism or British capitalism or
French capitalism or whatever so when it
says that how come you preach in
capitalism an immoral you know sort of
ideology and which type of capitalism do
you mean and let's ask them up
frame of references again sort of
largely the college university setting
and I'm not totally you know cuz I don't
totally believe it's a fruitless effort
to try to work some convincing of
economic principles at that level I
think that there are creative ways to
get students to see even if they're not
economics majors how economic principles
are valuable interdisciplinary efforts
pointing out in the classics of
literature Victorian novels other kinds
of older works that are classics the
economic principles they're students
that come from other disciplines English
literature and the humanities appreciate
that I think in the classroom itself
I very much appreciate coasts costa's
critique and really hoping his journal
that he helped to want to get founded
right before he passed away here not
that long ago gets going a non
mathematical sort of journal in
economics but games in the classroom
hands-on efforts are important I can't
think what also matters is from any
fruit well from some folks anyway what's
said in the pulpit you know what's
happening in the pulpit what's the
perspective of of capitalism they're the
efforts to increase the dialogue between
theologians and economists of bringing
the seminarians that are trained and
understanding economic principles could
be another venue as well we have time
for one more quick question
no you you've had one so let's see if we
have one more that hasn't had a chance
way in the back
hi there and I have a question a how
much damage do you think a the work of
Paulo Ferreira and the pedagogy of the
oppressed has done which was I'm from
Ireland and I was trained as a teacher
in Ireland and in a college that was T
with training people to be religion
teachers and it was required reading
parlor for Aires pedagogy of the
oppressed which is very powerful for
people of good faith and you know nice
people which is a Marxist analysis of
capitalism and I believe is used in
teacher training colleges all over the
world and I don't know if you're
familiar with the book and I wonder how
how prolific it still is thank you and
we're gonna let you have the last word
in terms of answering that sure well I I
am familiar with that line of thinking
and work ethic as well of in a Latin
American context of course coming out of
the 70s and 80s liberation theology as
well and the I think the influence of
Marx himself sort of wax and wanes in
seminaries I think postmodern thinking
regarding kind of relativism about
values is making inroads there yeah I
think it certainly is a metaphor that's
unfortunately tapped into many times by
theologians but again the hope is that
as people unpack the scriptures the
tradition of church teaching about what
it really means to be oppressed and and
and not to sort of take for granted that
oppression and here only comes from
capitalism and hopefully efforts like
this and others to counter that will be
helpful so thank you well Anita makes
her way to the podium for announcements
please thank our panel
you